the G20 Summit in Indonesia has ended
with a joint declaration that clearly
condemns the war in Ukraine even though
Russia is a G20 member the summit's
closing statement said leaders denounced
the war despite some divisions remaining
among the group Western leaders also met
on the sidelines of the G20 Summit to
discuss the missile explosion that
occurred on the Polish border last night
German Chancellor Olaf Schultz called
for a thorough investigation and he's
warned against drawing Hasty conclusions
Indonesia's president who hosted the G20
Summit called the incident in Poland
regrettable
[Music]
so why did Russia as a G20 member agree
to a declaration that basically condemns
its war in Ukraine I put that question
to DW's Alexandra phenom
well it's a very interesting question
because of course you would assume that
Russia would do anything to prevent the
strong condemnation of its war on
Ukraine from being included in the
official document and we put this
question to officials to Western
officials here in Bali and they told us
that it was a success for the Indonesian
presidency of the G20 they were reaching
out talking to every member of their G20
but they also stressed that Russia was
becoming increasingly isolated here with
more and more emerging economies India
for instance being in favor of such a
strong statement so they assume that in
the end Russia just didn't prevent this
statement from being published because
they didn't want to stand there totally
alone
all right let's go now to Jade McGlynn
she is a senior researcher at the
Monterey initiative in Russian studies
it's good to see you it's a different
story than it was 24 hours ago when we
last spoke
let me ask you why do you think Russia
agreed to this declaration at the G20
Summit a declaration that condemns
Russia for the war in Ukraine
I think that the way that they're
interpreting the Declaration and
certainly the way it's being
um spun to the extent that it's been
mentioned at all really in the program
Kremlin press is is quite different uh
to the way that we're discussing it so
it's the the focus is very much on the
notion that it's a sort of
ever it unanimously agreed that a
majority
um feel this way about the about the war
and so um there's much more stress um on
that side and also on the notion that
really you know the G20 isn't that
important that Western countries have
tried to put politicize it and we see
today that um Sergey lavrov has has
slunk off
um somewhat early earlier than he needed
to which probably says all that that
needs to be said about the extent to
which Russia has viewed um that Summit
is a success well does it say that but
what does it tell us actually does it
tell us that there is a level of
um embarrassment shame or maybe a level
from the Kremlin of
um disdain for what the G20 members
represent
I don't think it's disdain
um certainly because just for a start
China is a member of the G20 and
certainly Russia is not in a position
um to be expressing disdain towards
towards China I I would see it as
frustration but I think that even going
into the G20 the expectations were were
very low
um and of course there were rumors about
Sergey lavrov's heart problems
um which he denied but which Indonesian
officials seem to confirm so that maybe
another aspect as well
um that's that's playing on the decision
to leave but overall expectations were
low and I think even those low
expectations were not really in there
and what about China at the G20 I wonder
if you think China was trying to have
its keg and eat it too I mean right
before the the summit the president of
China met with the U.S president and
they came out together condemning the um
the threat of the use of nuclear weapons
obviously that was meant for blood let
me put him but you also have China as
one of the parties at the G20 that was
insisting that this communique and not
be as strongly worded in its
condemnation it seems like China is
trying to dance you know at the same
time at two weddings if you will
Summit is rather
um is having it's having its cake and
eating it
I mean I suppose from China's point of
views as well it might
um they
of course are a partner of of Russia's
they they know that
um you know on many occasions they they
share
um they have shared interests they have
sort of common interests and and I think
it's fair to say common
um autocratic values
um but that's not to say that you know
China doesn't fully trust Russia China
does not
um want is not particularly impressed by
the decision
um to go to war or at least has been
very um Keen to make it public that
they're not especially impressed by this
decision to go to war they were quite
sharp words not only from China but also
from India when the nuclear rhetoric had
ratcheted up you know far to I mean any
any amount is too high but especially
High exceptionally High a couple of
months ago so um I don't think we're
seeing anything particularly out of the
ordinary China is very cautious um in
its moves and and we see that continuing
Russia analyst Jade McGlynn we
appreciate your time and your insights
tonight just like we did last night
thank you
all right we want to go back now to our
reporter chege zimanovski he is in
eastern Poland where that missile struck
about 24 hours ago
um let's start with the view from where
you are there in Poland what impact has
this strike had on the residents in the
village there
yes we just arrived in the village of
chavadov which where the explosion where
the accident yesterday happened you can
see
the police cars behind me the police
have cordoned off the area just a few
hundred meters behind me there is this
grain drying facility where the missiles
track and the two people have died I was
able to speak to the head of this of
this community here just half an hour
ago he was visibly tired exhausted beat
down you could even say but and he said
that people here are really hoping that
these news we all heard today that this
in fact was a Ukrainian
anti-aircraft missile and not a Russian
one uh that's this true that this news
proves to be true and this in fact has
been and indeed a tragic accident and
not the beginning of a possib of a
possibly bigger conflict so there is
also a sense of grief he was talking
about he said that the these two people
that were killed these two men were well
liked here you know this is a very
closed-knit Community it's just 400
people Village so you know there is he
said that there is a long way to go for
them but they are strong together and
they will overcome the situation
how worried are people in the The Border
area there how worried are they that
this could happen again you know a lot
of people are saying they're surprised
that it didn't happen sooner
right just as I said I think this is a
mixture of this fear and Terror with
some sort of a relief that this day
today brought
we are hearing the escalatory rhetorics
on the political level so people here
for hope that this will uh that this
will stay this way or that this will
prove to be true because you know they
know that should anything happen they
are the first ones to really experience
this you know they and they told me that
they experienced this
um very well right at the beginning of
the Russian invasion this year uh you
know since the 24th of February the
people here we are just six kilometers
from the Ukrainian border these are the
people here that were you know the first
ones to receive Ukrainian refugees you
know in uh so uh so Dave they say
they've grown closer together as a
community
due to this extreme situation and you
know even one of the men that's that's
died today that was killed yesterday I'm
sorry uh and is was known in the
community for going very often to the
border for helping the Ukrainian
refugees you know so they
um so they they are experiencing this
conflict here very
um intensively yeah exactly right I mean
we could talk about it from a distance
but where where you are I mean it is
right there it's impossible to ignore
DW's chegos simanovski reporting tonight
from Oakland thank you